but see they don't know that we know
that they know bet you didn't know
Courtney and Jennifer originally
auditioned for each other's roles before
talking producers into swapping that or
that Ross was written with David in mind
lots of internet articles will tell you
that Jane Lynch auditioned for Phoebe
but here's the truth not me no no I did
an audition for Phoebe from friends what
I did an audition for anybody on friends
yeah I didn't have a good representation
back then same goes for John Favreau and
the role of Chandler no I read that
that's I never even auditioned for that
it was a cool character I would have
been so happy to be on a show like that
but they both did appear as guests on
the show John did six episodes as
Monica's boyfriend
I bought a restaurant and I would like
you to be the head chef
the show was originally called six of
one that's the pilot script with the old
title signed by all the friends but get
this season 10 almost didn't happen
it's rumor Jennifer was ready to move on
from playing Rachel and that Brad didn't
want her to do it either but she agreed
to come back because everyone else
wanted to just take a break and the
tight-knit cast had a private huddle
before every show so shooting the final
episode was emotional for everyone but
it kind of sent Matt over the edge I had
quit smoking in the last episode I
started smoking again
it was very it was very sad so awkward
hug or lame cool-guy handshake no a lame
cool-guy handshake
[Music]
did you know Lisa Kudrow actually
couldn't play the guitar in fact she
suggested that Phoebe played the bongos
wait a minute it wouldn't make the show
a lot like your singing it would have
been destined for the blooper reel just
like these moments because you know what
the easiest friend to crack up on set
that'd be Lisa who used to stop
production because she couldn't stop
laughing the biggest pranksters who
ruined everybody else's take bad be Matt
and Matthew of course Oh Soap Opera
Digest
as more the cutest scene-stealers is his
dad it's been and he's bad dad oh you
might as well say it because I told you
but with shoot nights that could go as
late as one in the morning everyone got
a little punchy sometimes do it okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]